[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
en las últimas semanas una vieja ruta
concentra la atención de las noticias
sobre migración hacia europa el océano
atlántico es la opción para miles de
personas que buscan llegar al viejo
continente ante la estricta vigilancia
que se registra por el cruce del mar
mediterráneo miles han navegado en
pequeños barcos desde las costas
africanas rumbo al archipiélago español
de las islas canarias en el tránsito
cientos han muerto y los que logran
pisar sólo español están hacinados y las
islas desbordadas ante el arribo masivo
de los que huyen las cifras de los
inmigrantes están en 2020 que superan ya
hasta diez veces las llegadas
registradas el año anterior ante lo que
pasa en las islas canarias ya se escucha
una desafortunada comparación y la
pregunta de si estamos hablando de un
nuevo el esposo
el puerto ahora es una instalación
improvisada para estos recién llegados
más de 1600 inmigrantes arribaron a las
islas canarias en sólo dos días cifra
que no se había visto en más de una
década y los datos de recién llegados
siguen aumentando al tiempo que se
agudiza la situación en el archipiélago
se llama trato inhumano y degradante
porque porque en 400 metros cuadrados no
se pueden asignar 1980 personas
porque primero no son ganados segundo
son seres humanos tercero no hay
condiciones de salubridad ni de higiene
para atenderlos debidamente el
territorio español se encuentra a sólo
100 kilómetros de la costa norteafricana
y a medida que la unión europea toma
medidas enérgicas contra los cruces
fronterizos alrededor del mediterráneo
los migrantes están favoreciendo cada
vez más esta ruta
desde el comienzo del año más de 17.000
personas han realizado este viaje un
peligroso periplo que también es mortal
se sabe que más de 400 personas murieron
a lo largo de esta ruta no corrido de
2020 tratando de hacer la travesía en
embarcaciones inseguras como estas que
siguen llegando los residentes de las
canarias recuerdan con la actual crisis
migratoria los hechos vividos en 2006
cuando unas 30.000 personas llegaron a
las islas grancanaria tenía que haber
tenido habilitado ya desde aquel
entonces unas instalaciones dignas para
acoger a estos inmigrantes y la verdad
que se vergüenza que españa y europa
estén dando esta respuesta la afluencia
de inmigrantes se produce semanas
después de que 140 personas se ahogaron
frente a la costa de senegal la
embarcación se dirigía a las canarias y
es el peor naufragio en lo que va del
año
desde marruecos nuestra corresponsal
sofía català nos habla de los motivos
que llevan a miles de africanos a migrar
por esta ruta escuchemos
el endurecimiento del control migratorio
en el mediterráneo ha llevado a muchas
personas migrantes a asumir rutas más
peligrosas como es el caso de las rutas
que pasan por el océano atlántico en
dirección a las islas canarias desde
marruecos mauritania y senegal a saleh
en embarcaciones no aptas para navegar
repletas de hombres mujeres y niños que
huyen de situaciones violentas como
pueden ser en guerras o la pobreza
estructural que tiene lugar en el
continente y estas personas viajan de
forma irregular porque no tienen acceso
a los visados que exige la unión europea
para transitar por vías seguras y aún
así están llegando alrededor de mil
personas migrantes cada semana las islas
canarias pero otras muchas pierden su
vida en el océano atlántico según el
colectivo caminando fronteras que
monitorean las fronteras europeas aquí
en marruecos en lo que va de año más de
700 personas han desaparecido en el
océano atlántico a las que cabe sumar la
reciente desaparición de 480 ciudadanos
senegaleses en una sola semana y desde
senegal concretamente asociaciones de
apoyo a los trabajadores aseguran que
ahora mismo hay tanta gente emigrando
del país porque no hay peces
y muchos jóvenes dependen del sector de
la pesca el motivo es que el estado ha
firmado acuerdos pesqueros con la unión
europea y los pescadores locales no
tienen medios para competir contra los
grandes buques europeos que extraen el
pescado y lo transfieren a su mercado y
frente a dicha crisis migratoria el
gobierno español informó que
intensificará la seguridad con patrullas
navales y abrirá campamentos para los
migrantes pero que otras medidas se
están tomando sofía català nos cuenta
tras su llegada a las islas canarias las
personas que acaban de ser rescatadas
del océano atlántico reciben una orden
de expulsión y son retenidas en
condiciones deplorables concretamente en
el muelle de arguineguín ha llegado a
haber alrededor de 2.000 personas
afinadas bajo carpas y retenidas durante
más de 72 horas algunas incluso hasta
dos semanas y amnistía internacional y
la comisión española de ayuda al
refugiado han denunciado ante el
defensor del pueblo que la mayoría de
personas migrantes que llegan a las
islas canarias no reciben atención
jurídica también algunos letrados han
denunciado que la policía nacional
restringe el acceso a los puertos donde
se encuentran los migrantes y los
letrados acaban firmando órdenes de
expulsión de personas que no han podido
ejercer su derecho a pedir asilo y por
otra parte el ministerio del interior ha
montado un gran campo para poder retener
a las personas que se encuentran en el
muelle hasta que se decida si van a ser
acogidas en algún centro o si serán
expulsadas del país en este sentido y ha
habido un vuelo de deportación con
ciudadanos de diferentes nacionalidades
hacia
mauritania y mientras en canarias se
articula lo que a todas luces es podría
ser un nuevo les gusta el cómo califican
asociaciones de defensa de derechos
humanos también se sigue reforzando la
externalización del control migratorio y
una prueba de ello es que españa ha
ofrecido a marruecos 130 vehículos 4x4
por el valor de 7 millones de euros para
ser empleados en la persecución de
personas migrantes
acnur y la organización internacional
para las migraciones informó que ayudará
a gestionar la crisis migratoria que se
registra en las islas canarias hasta que
inmigrantes de france 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan
conectados con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]